Bristol Palin reveals she recently had
her ninth breast reconstruction surgery
it's a work in progress on Wednesday the
former Teen Mom OG star and daughter of
former Alaska Governor Sarah Palin
shared this snap to her insta story
wearing a bra bandages and what appears
to be surgical drains with red fluid
writing that she had her ninth
reconstruction surgery to fix a botched
breast reduction she had when she was 19
years old Bristol explains that the
initial surgery left her with damage of
muscle tissue and terrible scarring
adding that the whole situation has made
her very self-conscious her entire adult
life
praying that this is the last surgery
needed I hate being a whiner but it kind
of does put a setback slash pause on
life and that's why I've been fairly
M.I.A I look at my daughters and they
need a strong woman to look up to and
that's what I'm gonna give them
Bristol is mom to a 14 year old son trip
with her ex Levi Johnston a
seven-year-old daughter sailor and a
five-year-old daughter Atlee with her ex
Dakota Meyer I think we just try to do
the best with what we had in order to
stick into it for the kids and I think
we both realized it you know what
matters the most is putting the kids in
the best best environment and that's not
going to be us together Bristol and
Dakota tied the knot in 2016 and
divorced in 2018. their tumultuous
relationship playing out on Teen Mom OG
I'm not telling you I don't know I don't
know what's PTSD or what's not are you
kidding me you wonder why I go off the
rails and why it gets Amplified I think
that our marriage was something that was
very fast and he would agree to and
there's a lot of things that we probably
both wish we would have done differently
I think there's a lot of things that we
would advise our children to do
different absolutely now it seems
Bristol and Dakota are doing their best
to raise their kiddos together you know
being a father is the I mean is by far
there's no title that comes even as
close to that and and how I take that
serious I mean I love my daughters more
than I mean they are my world you know
last year Bristol shared this family
snap with her ex at their daughter's
Pre-K graduation writing in the caption
getting along as co-parents makes life a
lot easier put aside the past
differences Etc and focus on what's best
for your babes not losing sight of that
is everything
foreign